[Applause]
alright here's the idea here's the first
one I bought I don't know know why this
didn't sell us something a good idea to
me it's a coffee table book called dogs
who know you're having an affair
oh good you it only happened once yeah
and then look at this guy back here he
is he knows what you did and then this
one nothing mr. pickels yeah they know
there are coffee table books of street
art you know occasionally this one's
come to a book sound advice graffiti
that someone spotted look at that that's
just funny to me sound advice graffiti
diversify your portfolio remember to
pause right
this one right here sent your thermostat
to 68 degrees to save energy
pretty bad advice and look each five to
nine servings of fruits events it yeah
that's a great thing to be out there
telling me sure is
so I'm kid come on kids keep going while
at the railroad yard I like this one
it's very strange but I like it
Spike Lee distracted by lollipops and I
just it just makes me happy
oh boy blaming and apparently this
happens a lot I mean wherever he goes
people are trying to destruct look at
that one that me he's got his number
here's one you'll like Sean Spicer lying
about the room filling with water there
is no water in this room there is no
water in this room then we go to I don't
know where these water questions are
coming from then we're on to the water
is fake news and then finally I'm not
drowning you're drowning one's kind of
cute benedict cucumber batch there he is
as Sherlock Holmes
ah there he is as Alan Turing of course
inventing the first computer powerful
rule yeah and there he is as Doctor
Strange now this is interesting let's
examine we actually have footage of the
writer who wrote this cucumber joke
being congratulated right now
[Applause]
he did the right thing yeah and finally
this is my favorite coffee table book
and that's really saying something bad
spot for truck nuts these are bad spot
that's just a bad spot for drugs right
there you see those on the highway
why so bean why why so veiny and then
that's not right
is that any way to leave this
[Applause]
you